from thehill.com has the story 62
percent in a new poll say that federal
charges against Trump are politically
motivated that's from the Quinnipiac
University survey that was released on
Wednesday about these doj documents
Quinnipiac that is not exact that's not
you know that's not some right-wing uh
paid for Donald Trump internal poll from
his campaign or one of these super back
polls that gets pushed around every time
it's time to you know get more donations
out no no no this is Quinnipiac this is
a if anything this is a poll that's
that's going to diminish Trump support
and they're saying 62 percent of all
voters that's not even weighted yes
going into Democrats Independents Etc
look I think that people
and specifically voters in this country
to your point I think they're they're
busy right but they're not stupid they
may not be looking into all the little
details of everything that Hunter did
they're not gonna look into all the
little details of everything they're
alleging on Trump but they can see the
doubled standard in this case triple
standard they can see that there is a
different standard for those in power
who are favored and those who are in
power who are disfavored and and Sheamus
this is something that you and I were
talking about beforehand and
we're definitely going to get into this
more in the members only hour because
this is the type of situation
and Ian I'd love to hear your thoughts
on it as well this is the type of
situation that leads to instability this
is the type of situation that leads to
people checking out of the system
because they don't believe in the system
anymore this is the type of situation
that says to people look if they come to
arrest our guy if they're using the
power of the state if they're using the
power of force to go after our president
at the our leader our opposition leader
and if this is happening in any other
country we call it exactly what it is
yeah we called exactly the rest of your
opposition leader right you know this is
something that when people go after
Putin they say oh Putin arrested his
opposition leader exactly the main thing
imagine if Trump had right imagine if he
actually had put Hillary Clinton in jail
right exactly it would be about how we
were a fascist third world country you
you pointed out that about 60 percent of
Americans see this as ideologically
motivated when it comes to the charges
against Donald Trump part of what
concerns me as it's almost inevitably
the case that some some number of that
sixty percent of people not only believe
it was politically motivated but think
that it was also a good thing so some
large number of people probably say it
wasn't politically motivated and that's
why I believe Justice is being served
here but there's likely a contingency
that really does believe that this was
politically motivated and it's good that
it was politically motivated because
they believe in arresting their
political opposition because they know
that they're on the side of Truth virtue
Etc all the self-aggrandizing things
that they would say to promote their
ideology when it comes to this question
of political instability I remember what
we heard repeatedly through the 2020
riots in order to justify the violence
that was happening in the streets was
that rioting is the language of the
unheard if that's true why are you
trying so hard to silence the right in
this country if you genuinely believe
that people become violent when they
don't have the proper political channels
it is an outlet to have their voices
heard what do you think is going to
happen if you arrest the leader of the
Republican Party a former president and
the front-runner for the upcoming
election this is the problem right this
is the problem I mean this could this
could get dangerous this is what leads
people to instability this is what we've
seen happen in country after country
this is what leads people to say
and we don't want this I don't want this
no my kids I don't want anyone who says
they do is a larper I don't want my
family I don't want that to live through
something like this but at the same time
we also can play things out and this is
something that Tim Prime has been
talking about here on the show for years
for absolute years saying that we're
seeing this type of instability go back
go if you had told somebody 10 years ago
10 years ago that we would see the
president United States House raided
that we would see the opposition
president arrested that if you and if
you if you take the lefts uh the left is
out there saying there already was an
Insurrection okay they that's their
claim they're the ones who have already
said that the Insurrection had 1.0
already began and so you were pushing
people further and further out of the
system at the same time when you refuse
to look into and YouTube says we can
talk about this now if you refuse to
look into election irregularities if you
refuse to look into the way that ballots
are counted the way the ballots are done
because we threw generations of
traditions out the window in the name of
covid in 2020 then double download it in
2022 in places like Maricopa County
where uh where Kerry Lakes voters were
turned away in droves saying that we
can't vote we can't count the ballots
are not printed right put them in door
three oh don't worry door three is going
to be fine these Maricopa County
machines etc etc don't worry it'll all
be counted will be taken care of people
turned away they went home when you
don't when you last point is when people
don't believe in the Integrity of the
system it leads them to seek alternate
options yep yeah but I I would also
argue because again I'm in Los Angeles
we you know one of the things that I do
differently than I would argue a lot of
people is that I'm directly involved
with the community and and I I know what
what their needs are I know what they're
asking for but the reality is is that
you know and I'll be honest I voted for
Donald Trump 2020 but his biggest fault
is to continue to push that narrative
and it's great you can believe in
irregularities Etc but guess what out in
Florida uh you know you had some of the
strictest election laws passed by Ron
DeSantis Democrats are still winning in
in in Florida you have people that you
know are uh winning in mayoral seats out
there in Florida why because Republicans
I'll be very honest with you man
Republicans are sometimes losers I'd say
about over 90 percent of Republicans
conservatives Christians they have this
defeatist attitude this dumer attitude
about everything uh you know there's a
lot of people that flee California I'll
be honest with you I I've planted my
banner of Christ in Los Angeles I have
no plans on leaving ever because I I
refuse to seed a single inch to Godless
people to the Communists whatever it is
I I kind of hate and I am kind of like
kind of sick and tired of seeing
conservatives often post you know and
Jack uh or Tim 2.0 I apologize for this
but sometimes when we tell people like
it's time to flee the cities it's like
dude when when you're at War you need to
reinforce warriors on the front lines
and you saw you saw it for yourself man
you came to Los Angeles uh you you got
to see all the Catholics out there you
saw the Protestants out there fighting
back Armenian parents are starting to
fight back man like in no way shape or
form can I believe and I'm new to this
party I I was never political before I I
didn't even vote 2016. I'm new to the
conservative side I just believe that
due to my Christian upbringing I'm just
naturally conservative and you know my
whole family votes Republican now but
it's alarming to me to see the party of
1776ers that you're not going to take my
guns the you know we need to fight back
convincing people convincing Christians
this is the most alarming to me is you
need to abandon all these parts of
America and just Flee for safety and the
problem with that is it's not going to
be the ballot harvesting it's Wisconsin
just overturned the Supreme Court right
the the Supreme Court at the state level
Arizona just went blue we're not winning
swing States why because we are
convincing conservatives and Christians
abandon our hope it's time to head to
high ground and people are going to one
of three places Tennessee uh Texas or
Florida there is no Christian there is
no conservative saying you know what
maybe our votes don't count here in
California maybe we should move to swing
state Michigan and help make it more red
that's not the message being promoted
and when you have a again no no fault to
Trump maybe a little bit of fault but if
all you're doing is going around telling
people the system is rigged there is no
hope look in my County our we had a
Republican state assembly woman and she
lost by 577 votes the reason she lost
was because over 30 000 Republicans in
my district didn't want to go vote
they're like what's the point if and and
the thing is when you have Christians
this is again if you're you know atheist
if you are you know a liberal or more
libertarian I can maybe understand it
but if you're a Christian conservative
your message to Christians should never
ever ever be I mean dude his disciples
of Jesus Christ were sent to the most
extremist places on Earth and he said
you will be persecuted for it so to me
it's kind of alarming to see so many and
so it's it's not going to be the ballot
harvesting it's just there's going to be
no Republicans left and and to talk
about the institutions you know people
want to be upset at Elon Musk because he
hired you know this NBC person but what
conservative is out there telling people
hey guys don't flee the cities actually
become a judge become a lawyer so that
we actually have a fair fight at when it
comes to crimes oh but the radical D.A
okay but who's running against that D.A
where are our conservatives I mean
there's so many Reds say people yeah
people flee to Florida their people flee
to Texas and they're harboring all this
power and money but then those states
are also not becoming as red as people
want to say so now we're losing
Wisconsin we're losing swing States we
just lost Arizona I I wish I I could sit
here and tell you it's the ballot
harvesting it's not it's just that
Republicans have been convinced it's all
over this is it Donald Trump didn't win
bro let me tell you something man like
it's way more than Donald Trump it is
you at the local level there's so many
people that have fled California to Safe
States they've never ever held the
campaign never donated five dollars to a
local school board member and they're
just like oh I'm done and I'm like but
you never started you just you just
listened to your local conservative that
said it's time to leave California
there's a senator Scott Wilk who just
said that there was one bill that was
just passing well let's let's see I
think I think there's a couple things to
to deconstruct here firstly I don't
entirely disagree with you uh I think
there is some wisdom in saying it could
be good for conservatives to move to
swing States as opposed to states that
are already solidly red so they can help
those States
turn red or flip red in in local
elections and particularly presidential
elections that would be massively
helpful however I think a person
ultimately does have to make the
decision that's best for their own
family and if they're concerned about
moving to a state where their child is
going to be told by some groomer teacher
that they're actually a member of the
opposite sex and then put on puberty
blockers and then the child's gonna be
taken from the parent I would say that's
a realistic concern to think about and
so it makes sense for people to say I'm
going to go to a solidly red State
because while you're correct the
apostles did go to dangerous places at
some point it is time for lot and his
family to leave Sodom and Gomorrah
because it's going to be destroyed and
I'll also say if your plan is to go into
Nineveh and convert those people you'd
better be a Jonah right and even Jonah
had his flaws but you you you really
have to be in a solid place I think to
be capable of persuading people
especially in a very dark area a very
evil area of embracing truth so while on
the one hand I think some of what you're
saying is admirable about wanting to
stay in fight and not giving up your
territory I totally hear all of that
that said it's perfectly reasonable for
somebody with a family to say you know
what I see what's coming down the pike
here I see the the Christian persecution
that's ahead of us and I want to get my
family somewhere more safe where they
can flourish but look man I I have I
have three children a 16 14 and 7 years
old all of them are in public education
they see what's happening with the
public education Los Angeles but it is
my job as a father first and foremost
and also as a parent to teach them
they're exposed to lgbtism I tell them
hey we're we are Christians we don't
believe in everything that they believe
we believe marriage is between one man
and one woman and guess what my son just
got baptized last year despite laus D in
the public education everyone wants
something oh get them out of the schools
but why I mean you know it's a
relatively good school outside of some
of the stuff that they are teaching them
but my son 16 years old I was able to
raise him raise them right he's a
Christian young man he got baptized last
year my daughter 14 years old she just
accepted Jesus Christ as the Lord and
Savior got baptized just a couple weeks
ago the reality is that it is your job
as a parent to parent you know people
say like oh I don't co-parent with the
government dude if you pay taxes you're
already co-parenting because you're
funding a lot of stuff that are going to
affect your children are going to affect
everything that you do in life and the
reality is if I'm able to do it and and
I agree with you there are some people
that really have to go but I think it
should be a last measure you know there
was a a post by captured he posted you
know here's five rules to save your
family uh rule number one get the hell
out of your blue State second one is go
buy land in the middle of nowhere uh uh
in a red State the third one is grow
your own food Fourth is homeschool your
children five pat yourself in the back
because you just save your children bro
there's a lot of homeschool uh uh kids
that are not right you know like just
because you homeschool it's not a
promise of of be uh of being raised
right or you're not going to be raised
conflict there's a lot of people that
homeschool and unfortunately their
children go off to college or university
or whatever it is but my argument is not
against people that hey if it's right
for you but the reality is a lot of the
people that I speak with that leave
California it's because of one thing and
it's it's it's mostly economical and
they're like hey you know what uh my
house has become I can't buy a house out
here whatever it is
um uh you know and and so I need to move
to a different state to pay lower taxes
to to pay less in gas prices Etc but I I
just don't believe in that personally
man I I just don't I don't think I was
put on this Earth to pay low gas prices
I'll deal with the gas prices by working
harder making more money and I and I get
the children's stuff but it you know let
my testimony not be the standard or to
be exalted but to show to people people
dude even in deep blue Los Angeles on
the front lines of Communism where
antifa and black lives matter basically
run the city council dude here we are
baptizing kids because there is a need
for that and let my children you know my
son when he started school last year
he's in he's going to 11th grade now
he's like hey Dad just to let you know
there's two trans kids that are are
changing out in our locker room like
well what do you mean by that they're
like well it's two girls that pretend to
be boys and so they're allowed to be in
the locker room you know what I told
them I didn't tell them like oh you
better start standing up that I just
said you know what son that is their
lifestyle we don't agree with it thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time